no we're going to go into a recession
now
The Whole World's Gonna Be upside down
and if we don't get a budget
oh
we have to get a budget
what's the commitment
people aren't going to get paid
enough
well the military is not going to get
paid nobody's bills are going to be paid
yeah but this is what they're
threatening and it's like it false new
fake news
no one no is that yours that's mine
that's the one that you already sent is
that this one
I printed it out
but I wrote on it
I just wanted everybody to hear me
thank you
good afternoon representative uh Mason
will be with us shortly
opening the executive session on Senate
Bill 42 FN
relative to the overpayment of
unemployment compensation
Vice chairman seaworth I'd like to make
a motion uh ought to pass with Amendment
second
motion is made in second your
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you Mr chairman
um I have
prepared an amendment on this bill I
think I passed it out to everyone who
needed a copy if not there are copies on
the table
um first of all
I think I I know I speak for myself I
would say most of the committee maybe
all of the committee we support and
appreciate the work that Employment
Securities does to make sure that
workers who are unemployed
get the support to which they're
entitled I I don't think that's a
controversial statement
um
I'll also add that for me every time
that the department comes in and and
speaks on an issue of the details of how
they are administered administrating
their programs I learned something and I
usually learn a lot
um briefly and maybe my kind of briefly
hopefully not uh I'll cover some of that
because I know not everyone was here
during the public hearing
um this bill addresses a situation where
let's say I'm an unemployed worker and I
file for benefits
does everybody have the copies I know I
have a whole stack here but I want to
make sure everyone in the committee has
the amendment for
um Senate Bill 42 which is 2023-1799h
yes okay I just want to make sure I
still have a pile here thank you go
ahead continue
um
so yes the situation is I'm in I'm an
employee I file for uh benefits and
receive money to which I am not entitled
and uh what I learned is that there are
three specific cases to this
two of which this bill doesn't touch at
all and the third of which the bill and
the amendment deal with the first is
where it's through absolutely no fault
of my own
I did everything as as best I understood
the process money comes to me that I
shouldn't have had and in that case I
don't I get to keep it I don't have to
pay it back and I I think we all agree
that that's fair
um and just and maybe in some cases a
little generous but I I don't think any
of us have an issue with that part
the second process is where I have
fraudulently decided I'm going to go get
some money that I am not entitled to and
I I do something to to take that money
essentially I'm stealing money from the
other workers in New Hampshire who need
and are entitled to those benefits in
that case
um
first of all there's a process where if
the department says that's what I did
there's an administrative process for
them I can I can object I can appeal
once that's decided I have 60 days to
give the money back if I don't give the
money back then it begins accruing
interest
um
and furthermore and this I learned
that's probably the least of my worries
because I've committed a criminal act
and the department is almost certainly
going to come after me with criminal
charges
again
this bill doesn't touch that I I think
we all think that's a fair way to deal
with somebody who's stealing money
what this bill goes after is the third
case which is in between the two I did
something
improper it is my fault that I am now
receiving those benefits to which I am
not entitled
um but it doesn't rise to the level of
criminality
so in that case the original Bill said
well the the original we'll start with
the original Law the law says again
there's there may be an administrative
process where we can determine whether I
am in fact in that category once that's
determined I have 60 days to pay back
the money if I do not then there will
begin to accrue interest on the portion
of the money I still owe
the bill says no
after 60 days if I don't pay the money
back
but I still owe it but there's no
penalty for not paying it back my
amendment I think
it kind of splits the difference and in
a way that is useful it despite the
length of the amendment
um it really only changes that shell the
department shall charge zero percent
interest to a may it it gives the
discretion to the department to charge
up to the one percent that's currently
in statute
anything in between including zero so
they will now through their rules have
the discretion to Define well when is
charging interest
necessary or helpful and when is waiving
the interest in the best interest of
everyone involved
um
as I said the LA it's a lot of words for
changing a shell to a may we did work
with the Department in coming up with
this this is by and large the language
that they suggested to do what we want
to do and do it right there's a couple
of changes that OLS made but other than
that this is the way the people who
administer this program told us is the
right way to do it
in my opinion uh amended this way this
accomplishes most
of what the original Bill intended to do
it might avoid some unintended
consequences where you
where someone just won't pay back the
money that they owe and you have no
incentive to ask them to do it
um
and so I
hope that everyone will support this
bill as amended thank you questions
representative Sullivan
thank you Mr chairman
um
I I will say I do support the bill
um I do not support the amendment I told
the chair yesterday that I would listen
with an open mind but since that time
I've really looked at it and thought
about it
um and that middle category is one that
gives me some concern
um the um and there's a two basic issues
that I've got with it
um
the first is providing discretion to the
department and this is not saying
anything negative about the department
but basically it allows the department
to to decide who pays interest and who
doesn't and
um
not having seen the rules at this point
that uh where the rules will be very
specific or very or somewhat broad
I have a concern against bias we all
have bias we live in a country that uh
deals with discrimination and I would
hate to find somewhere down the line
that interest is being charged to
various specific segments of the uh
um the population while not being
applied to others and again I probably
wouldn't be intentional but it could
happen because bias exists
um so um
that's my first concern
my second concern is um
with the type of folks who might find
themselves in the situation
a lot of people who end up on
unemployment
are really living hand to mouth and they
really and by the time the mistake is
identified they may have gotten several
payments they would have spent those
payments and now they're being required
to not only pay them back but
potentially pay interest on it paying it
back is a real problem for a lot of
people because you already spent it it's
gone
um so they don't really have the money
to pay it back and that creates a
challenge for a lot of folks
um but uh charging interest on top of
that
um could make it a very difficult
situation for people who are really on
Hard Times
um so um you know I'm I'm more
comfortable with the status quo of uh
charging interest when someone commits
fraud no problem with that if you
um if you steal from
Employment Security you ought to be
penalized with interest and with the
criminal
um
consequences as well but if you make an
honest mistake
even if it's a foolish mistake it's not
a simple process maintain you've got to
apply every week as we all know in any
one of those weeks you can make them
make an error and if that error
turns out to um
cause your payments to be too high yes
you should pay it back but no you should
not pay interest so I would be in
opposition to the amendment thank you
representative Cahill
thank you Mr chair
um
as I understand it the current practice
of the department is not to seek blood
from the stone
and I think they already have the
ability to weigh whether or not
something was intentional certainly that
and whether or not it's worth the
expense to pursue something
and so I really I think I'd also like to
understand have a better understanding
of an example or two of a situation
where it's not fraud it's not their
fault but it kind of is their fault but
they didn't do it on purpose I'd like to
well I wonder if Mr lavers could help
clarify a couple of these issues for us
if he'd be willing
I'm sure he could
I don't know if he's willing
well he didn't come here for nothing
Jessica
waivers welcome
good afternoon uh thank you just for the
record Richard laborers Deputy
Commissioner Employment Security
um so so just to clarify a few points as
we've talked about before and I think
representative seaworth a very
um
um he's clearly been listening when I've
been talking so that's good I appreciate
that
um
when someone is paid benefits for which
they are later determined to be
ineligible because it's an eligibility
based program we're not we're not an
entitlement program eligibility based
program and that eligibility goes week
to week when your paid benefits for
which you should not have been paid and
it is not your fault
the department made a mistake
the employer made a mistake
you never have to repay those benefits
right you're you're waived of those it's
payments out of the trust fund that you
should not have received but we're
you know we call it for what it is we
screwed up you keep that
here we're talking about benefits that
are paid for which you are later
determined not to be eligible
but it's not the eligibility issue that
came into question
is not one where the department screwed
up it's not one where the employer
screwed up it's one where the individual
provided information or did not provide
information which
they knew was inaccurate or information
they knew was relevant and needed to be
provided and they didn't
so in that situation where we make a
determination that you are with fault
you have to repay and there's interest
that accrues
now like all determinations that get
issued from the Department you have an
opportunity to challenge that you
receive that determination you disagree
with it you have a period of time of 14
days to file an appeal
you have an opportunity for a de novo
hearing a brand new Hearing in front of
a hearing officer
and you can make your pitch you can make
your story as to why you feel
that the characterization of you being
with fault was wrong
if you disagree with the decision issued
by the appeal hearing officer you can
again appeal that
if you disagree with the decision on
review of that appeal hearing officer's
decision
you can appeal that to our appellate
board and ultimately if you disagree
with the Appellate board you can go to
the New Hampshire Supreme Court
so there's a lot of there's multiple
layers of opportunity if you feel the
department has simply not heard you
or has inaccurately characterized your
behavior and actions taken that led to
you being paid when you were not
eligible
and it's only after that process is
completely exhausted
as much or as little as you want to
utilize
that the department then has a situation
where you are considered overpaid
and need to repay that back
60 days from that date if you still owe
that debt or a portion of that debt
interest starts to accrue
so that's that's the situation we're
looking at
and now
particular
um examples of
situations where someone could be found
to be with fault
but might not rise to the level of fraud
and they'd be in this camp this this
group that we're looking at here
perhaps you mischaracterize the
circumstances of your separation
so you file your initial claim
you provide us with a description of
what happened
the employer maybe doesn't immediately
respond
we make an effort to get that response
but the employer doesn't immediately
respond
we pay you benefits
the employer then responds providing us
more credible information as determined
by
a certifying officer at the department
that the way you characterize your
separation was not correct
it was not accurate it was unreasonable
in what you characterize it as based
upon better information more reliable
information provided by the employer
now you're going to be overpaid
and would be with fault
another situation perhaps
you were a little bit
fast and loose with your
description of your work search efforts
on a weekly basis so each week you have
to certify to the department what you
did
for activities and Outreach in order to
stay connected to the labor market to
satisfy that Weekly work search
requirement and maybe we find that some
of it some of it wasn't true
an employer that you say you outreached
to you've submitted a resume to
the employer then says this did not
happen
or certain activities that you say that
you did perhaps attending a job fair
that we put on and we come to find out
that you did not attend
in that situation we're going to find
that you are overpaid and with fault
and you're going to have the opportunity
to appeal it you're going to have the
opportunity to challenge it
But ultimately
if it's decided that you are overpaid
with fault you'll have to repay the
benefits and you'll have to
have interest at a cruise while that
debt remains outstanding
um
what I what I think came across and and
listening and and hearing the the the
the sponsoring Senator Senator Whitley
talk about
the reasons for filing the bill and
others who are supportive of it there's
some concern around those situations and
how we are determining fault or without
fault
and then requiring someone to repay
those benefits in the interest that
accrues
and
I think the the rule making process can
actually serve a useful purpose in that
regard and I can't speak for other
agencies and how they utilize the
administrative rulemaking process but
how the department has done that
historically over the past decade
has been to work collaboratively with
New Hampshire legal assistance and
anytime we're looking to implement rules
that impact unemployment benefit
payments
we have a good track record I can say
that from the I think the department has
a good track record of working
collaboratively with them
it goes back to
close to 10 years ago when working
closely with Dan feltis and Sarah Matson
when we were looking to implement rules
on the compromise process
so the process that the department
implements when someone
seeks forgiveness of an overpayment
that was a very exhaustive process a lot
of meetings
um
I didn't get everything that
I originally wanted and probably neither
did Dan or Sarah but we've reached a
point where we were in agreement that we
had a good set of rules to have a
process in place for when people request
forgiveness of a debt
we then did the same thing more recently
with regard to an individual's ability
to continue to get paid benefits when
they are determined to to or they they
have initial eligibility and then they
lose eligibility at some point during
their claim and they file an appeal
there's a New Hampshire Supreme Court
decision that says in those situations
an individual can make an election to
continue to receive benefits knowing
full well if they are if they fail
they'll have to pay those back
we had rule we had rules that expired
we worked with New Hampshire legal
assistance we had a very valuable
discussion around the issue
and we proceeded with that rulemaking so
I think we have a good track record of
working with them working with legal
assistance I'll let them characterize it
or describe it however they they would
like but what we would do if this
amended Bill were to become law is we'd
have to start the rulemaking process
we would do that by starting with New
Hampshire legal assistance
having discussions like we've done
before
telling them these are situations where
we think interests should be charged
they could then describe to a situations
where they don't feel interest should be
charged and then we try to be able to
put that into appropriate language for
rules so that there there's a lack of
discretion
on the part of the department in
proceeding and that when our hearing
officers and our certifying officers are
are making that decision they have
hopefully clear guidance between statute
and rule on what they're supposed to do
given the circumstances
so you know
a couple of situations where interest
would accrue on a situation where
someone is found with fault
and a little bit of a explanation on how
the department would go about rulemaking
if
the amendment were to pass
um and I and I think
um
rulemaking can be very valuable
um it's a lot of work
people have other things they would
probably prefer to be doing
but rulemaking can be very valuable so
that the product that you get down the
road is something that all sides can
agree
is what we feel should be happening in
individual circumstances and again we
try to take the discretion out of it by
having
um
a good solid rule-making process and
good solid discussion for both sides
both the department and other interested
groups on where the concerns lie and how
can we can go go about addressing that
so that's what you know if this were
were to pass that's how the department
would implement it
thank you represent Cahill
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
Mr labors that was very helpful
this is not a hearing who are you and
why do you want to speak
Senator with
I'm sorry Senator I didn't know who you
are I've never met you before
um
feel free to speak
because I saw you shaking your head no
um thank you Mr chair I really do
appreciate the opportunity to speak I am
glad here because that I'm here because
I actually have not seen this amendment
um which is I I have to say it is
disappointing to me
um because the department actually
didn't oppose this bill in either the
senate or the house and so it's
surprising to me that they would work on
an amendment to really gut the bill and
that's what this amendment does it
really does gut the bill I think the
Senate felt pretty strongly that the
collection of Interest was really overly
punitive and that this bill was very
narrowly tailored to New Hampshire so I
think I mentioned in the hearing on this
bill that
the federal government actually does not
allow interest to be collected on any
overpayments whereas the bill was a more
narrowly tailored uh solution for New
Hampshire to prohibit the collection of
Interest where fraud was not involved so
I think the senate had worked really
hard to just think about a solution that
worked for New Hampshire residents the
collection of interest you know has not
been really shown to change behavior
um it doesn't it doesn't uh amount to a
significant amount of Revenue at all you
know I I believe it's less than 100 or
200 000 but yet for the people that it's
charged to it's very very very uh
dramatic and I will say the reason why
the Senate felt like this was such an
important policy
is that the people that were really
impacted but the people that lost the
most jobs frankly were women and the
women that who were at the front lines
and so this is a uh I I don't want I
don't like to make every issue a
gendered issue but the in this case we
know that the data is in particular
um women my age or younger than me
frankly at this point of you know our
working mothers they have not come back
to the workforce we saw a dramatic 10
percent uh
Exodus and they just haven't come back
to the workforce so I think instead of
thinking about policies to uh penalize
these people we should think about
policies to bring them back
um and so the other thing that I wanted
to mention is that
um you know when we're talking about you
know the different branches of
government of course do you have the
executive branch of which the department
is part of and we're the legislative
branch and I think this is a case where
you know the department has said again
when they did not oppose this in either
bodies they said this is a policy
decision for the legislature and so I
think the Senate was very clear in their
policy position that charging interest
in this tiny circumstances was really
overly punitive so I would encourage you
all to stake that
um put that stake in the ground as a
legislative branch and say you know it's
overly punitive it's not necessary we
got to get these folks back to work and
maybe this is a small way to do that so
I really appreciate everyone's time and
your thoughtful consideration of this
really important bill and I don't know
if people have questions but I'll stay
thank you
thank you very much Senator I'm not
going to open it up for hearing this is
not a hearing this is executive session
you know thank you Senator sorry I
didn't know who you were
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman I I want to clarify something
because there was a suggestion that
somehow the department is doing
something inappropriate I want to make
it very clear for the record that this
language
this was my request this was what I
thought would make the bill better
for workers and for the Department to do
the job that we ask them to do
um I suggested some language on my own I
sent it to the department for comments
and they came up with what I think is
better language and so that's why I
submitted what I did so I just want that
for the record thank you
any other comments we have a motion on
the floor with the amendment
representative love
thank you Mr chair uh if if I'm correct
here on this
this amendment um and from what uh
you know the the uh the
um
director said there uh there's degrees
of lying
um and if you you know you can tell a
white lie and maybe end up with a little
little extra extra cash here and you get
caught uh and we won't charge your
interest maybe but then there's other
degrees of lying where it's an outright
lie and and you were quiet and uh you
know and you will be charged the the um
you know the higher rate the one up to
the one percent
um I don't find anything wrong with that
I mean uh you know nobody should be
lying to get money uh it's it's plain
thievery and um you know I think this is
a
um more than a Great Compromise
thank you representative McKenzie
thank you Mr chair
um my experience with the unemployment
system is they have a fairly robust uh
set of rules and regulations and laws
as an employee
uh as a worker as somebody who has to
file in this system
negotiating through all of those
different things uh and making a mistake
along the way is not
it's not out of touch because many
people as you heard how difficult and
how many different aspects are out of
the system
um I think we've got enough uh in place
already
I think we have enough uh to that can
happen they can they can work with I
think there's there's enough rules and
regulations uh in the system
two things is for me is who helps the
employee through the process
the work that's with not the employee
working through the process uh and the
second thing what happens when when
somebody cannot pay that they don't have
the capacity to pay this money uh back
which for unemployed workers who've been
out for a period of time and all of a
sudden realize oh my goodness I have all
this uh you know have all this
responsibility now is that driving
people into bankruptcy so what is the
impact on that and how is it that this
the department tests their ability to
pay uh I don't think for the most part
people are lying necessarily I I mean
that's my opinion it's not fact uh but I
do think that people make mistakes and
mistakes that could get them in trouble
and probably not intentionally but if
you're an unemployed worker and you've
been out for a while and you're under a
lot of stress and your family is you
know you're worried about how you're
going to feed your family and how you're
going to pay your bills
um maybe you move too fast and maybe you
can make some mistakes along the way and
I think that Department currently has
the capacity in the infrastructure
within there within their uh their
current laws to deal with a lot of this
stuff I don't think we need this I don't
think we need more and to be honest with
you in uh in support of my colleague I
don't want discretion necessarily in the
law uh I think our responsibility you
know I did contracts for a long time I
don't like discretion I like things to
be stated clearly what the rules are and
what the expectations are for this uh
for anybody and I think laws should
should do that public policy should be
clear so I would object to the uh to
this amendment and we'll vote against it
Jim Madam Clerk
um he addressed most of what I was going
to say but I would love
to speak after the amendment vote
all right just seeing no other uh hands
I was also part of the amendment
the rest of the met with Brian we
discussed this and so uh I agree with
them don't blame the department you can
blame the two of us if you'd like
I'm kind of surprised
um it it what I'm hearing about the
discretion
because
the 16 or 18 years I've been hanging
around on this committee
we have let the Department of Labor have
a lot of discretion
almost all of our laws regarding
labor laws
say may versus shell
so when someone goes two years without
workers compensation and the bill is
sixty thousand dollars because it's
twenty five hundred dollars plus one
hundred dollars per person per day
we allow the department to have
discretion
more often than not they'll say well
what would workers comp if cost you for
those two years four thousand dollars
fine that's your fine
no worth not worth putting anyone out of
business
I rarely ever heard anyone say that the
Department of Labor
was not prudent
with the discretion that the legislature
has given them I see no reason to think
that Employment Securities would not
utilize their discretion
because there are some situations
where I believe they would very easily
not charge anyone interest
between someone who
just didn't understand a question and
how they answered it or someone that's
really close in the line of almost
committing fraud is a there's a big
difference there between those two
um
I do trust the department
with that discretion
um
and understand remember
whose money this is
employers pay it
employees need it there to have it there
when they need it
that's it and we try to keep it solvent
in the last two recessions we've kept it
solvent
so we didn't have to borrow money
um
so
maybe I am biased because I've been
hanging around here too long
and I trust what I've seen out of that
department through two recessions
but I will be supporting the amendment
so Madam Clerk
emotional
representative Prout sorry I thought
we're done
thank you Mr chairman sorry your words
inspired me no words
um I also am going to support the
amendment and the one of the reasons is
is we're seeing interest rates climb
high and what I don't want to see is
somebody compare
a essentially zero interest obligation
on one hand to what they can get from a
bank if they stall
and again as with you I trust the
department to use the discretion through
the rules that we give them to try to
draw the right line in in between those
circumstances
Madam clerk he inspired me
I just also would like to add being
inspired by that comment that
um I don't believe if the Employment
Security Office had underpaid and it was
determined later had underpaid an
employment to someone who was unemployed
they don't receive any interest on the
missed unemployment they get just the
basic rate and really that's what we're
talking about here is interest on
um unemployment that was not fraudulent
I feel like in the hearing originally
most of the discussion ended up being
about fraud even though that wasn't what
the bill discussed at all
um I could one thing I'll just plant a
seed in this for the future
um
if you haven't gone
through the unemployment process it is
eye-opening
a majority of what you're told
is about fraud and a video is shown of
people who had committed fraud and they
were as a part of their sentence or
agreement or whatever filmed saying
something pretty uh
potent
about don't commit fraud don't go to
jail like I did essentially and each
week you have to report what you earned
or didn't earn if you were if you look
for work all those things that we've put
in place as in the policy as legislators
you have to agree each week I did look
for work I with at least two employers I
did a report to the best of my ability
any money I earned in that week all
kinds of things are in it every week and
I will say
um that process is pretty cumbersome and
eye-opening and I think it would be
helpful to understand that process in
the future and
um
it kind of feels like being unemployed
is any stigma you have about you know
having your self-worth being tied to
your work uh the process while in many
ways reasonable does not help does not
help that so to add Notions about
um fraud in a bill that
doesn't say
anything about the interest for people
committing fraud
um
I think what was fair because the the
bill itself is discussing in the
non-fraud cases this is what happens
with interest rate
um for overpayments and again it doesn't
address underpayments if that's
determined later so I think in that way
it is a fairly
bipartisan
non-controversial straightforward bill
I hope that's helpful thank you
I'm glad everyone is inspired
representative well what I heard if I
could message you uh what I heard is
that
um there may be a conflict with the
federal law as it relates to this piece
of legislation
and I'd be interested in some I don't
know I guess it's too late to have
people uh give us some some feedback on
that but if that's the case then is this
uh is this out of um out of order uh at
this point
representative seaworth I'll try to
respond to that with the caveat that I'm
not an expert and could well get it
wrong my understanding with that comment
is that federal law does not charge
interest rates so the difference is with
our current law
forget the bill the way we do it now New
Hampshire charges interest which
is not in federal law
um
this either version of the bill would
neither fix the
that issue nor would it make it worse
both the original bill and the amendment
reduce interest so
um to the extent that someone perceives
a problem it would make it less so uh I
also
have to believe that if there were truly
a conflict that we were in violation of
any federal law that that would have
been brought up well before today
because the the issues are the way
the question is over the interest that's
currently in law and has been in law for
some time
and I
you know I know it's not a public
hearing so yeah well I've already the
Pandora's it's out of the box
Senator and then uh commissioner
uh thank you for the opportunity again I
would agree with representative seaworth
um about his characterization the only
difference that I would say is that it
is the state when the when there are
federal benefits involved it is the
state that administers them and federal
law says that the state can't charge
interest in any situation on those
Federal benefits
so
passage of the law as the Senate passed
it would just make
State policy consistent with federal
policy
did that answer question
assistant commissioner you have anything
to you would like to add
um just a real brief uh the bill was
provided to the U.S department of labor
for review as to whether there are any
issues they came back and said no
because it is at the discretion of the
state as to whether or not interest is
charged or not charged with State paid
benefits and that's what we're talking
about here the federal benefits we're
talking about we're talking about
federally funded benefits
when those get implemented like they did
during the pandemic New Hampshire
businesses aren't paying those out of
their taxes those are coming from
federal resources
and those come with rules and those
benefit programs any overpayment could
not have interest attached to it so
federally funded no interest state
funded the feds look at it and say State
you do what you want we're not going to
mess with your decision on that
Sullivan followed by Cahill
thank you Mr chairman
um
I wanted to speak again simply so I
could be a man of my word
um I did tell the chair I would listen
with an open mind and I have listened to
the senator to the Deputy Commissioner
and to my colleagues
um and um I will say that my um
I'm still in the same place I just
cannot support this amendment thank you
I appreciate it thank you Senator Gail
thank you Mr chair I believe Mr
Granger's hand was up and you may not
have seen it so I would yield to Mr
Granger provided I get my say afterwards
all right representative Granger sorry I
did not see you
I don't have anything to say that I'm
still mulling it it it seems to me as
though with with without interest
there's a possibility that someone could
make a like a lot of money off of the in
yeah there there seems to be a there's a
possibility of a scam Brewing but I
haven't figured it out and I don't want
to bring it forward without
it seems to me someone creative could
exploit this pretty heavily without any
interests thank you representative kale
thank you very much Mr chairman
um
I also have complete confidence in the
department and the and the discretion in
the way they have used it and continue
to use it and while I I don't know that
the amendment does harm it does sound a
Mr Labor's words like a lot of work to
go through rules and I think they're
already doing a good job at this already
so I will support the bill but not the
amendment
thank you
anyone else inspired
all right
we have a motion on the floor motions
um
move Amendment
move Amendment 1 7
2023-1799h it's been moved and seconded
science chairs I'm sorry I will uh Vice
chair seaworth yes
rep babyloni yeah
rep Prout yes
rep love yes Brett Boyd yes
rep Mason yes
rep Cole come yes
rep drego
yes
rep Granger yes ranking gem Sullivan no
reply Rudy no
we're at Cahill no
repti Silvestro no
Brett O'Brien no
Brett Bouchard no
reploid
no
Brett McKenzie no
the clerk votes no repliclair yeah in
the chair
watch yes
10 to 10. we have a tie does not
move forward
uh Bill's up for additional motion it's
under seaworth
I move itl
's ideal second by representative
discussion
oh I'm sorry just briefly you are sorry
um
one of the reasons that I that I decided
to work on an amendment is as I heard
the department discuss their process
um I realized that what we're taking
away with this bill is a tool in their
toolbox and I agree with my fellow
representative in the corner there they
have a process in place that allows them
to reduce
uh obligations it allows them to
schedule payment processes
um they already work with individuals
who are in this kind of gray area
looking at their circumstances looking
at their ability to pay and try to
adjust the payment
to that and what I heard during the
public testimony was several times it
was said well the one percent interest
that's in law we can't change that and
then it would go on to something that
they do do and uh
so
my solution which failed was well we can
change that but what I I cannot support
is completely taking away a part of the
process
um that that person who Maybe
deliberately
got themselves money to which they
weren't eligible but it's not quite
to the level that you can prove that
that there's some
veneer of deniability in it
um and
maybe that person never intends to pay
back the money and to take away the one
tool that the department has to say you
know what after 60 days that you have to
start paying us back
I don't I can't see taking that away so
that's why I've moved Ito
um I just wanted to reiterate I was a
little iffy when I said this a little
bit ago but now I'm going to say it more
clearly this is a bipartisan Bill
Senators Carson Innis and Lang and
representative McGuire are co-sponsors
um I know representative McGuire fairly
well she and I typically do not agree on
economic issues so that she was willing
to support this bill as a co-sponsor I
think says a lot and that is my only
point there was a Mackenzie followed by
groups of Gail thank you
Mr chairman there's been a lot of work
uh that's gone into this from the Senate
and we've also worked on it as I as I
understand this this is a very narrow
group of people
and this narrow group of people uh uh
now or it could essentially be in two
different systems they're in
unemployment in the state system for a
while and then they trigger on to the
federal benefits so that's a whole other
environment so to me that introduces
another level of uh confusion for
unemployed workers who are trying to
navigate through the system I think what
the what as I understand it and what the
senator said is this and and by
bipartisan support we might add is that
this is simply a way of aligning the
state policy with the federal policy so
that this is the same rules under which
people operate again it's a very narrow
group of people to get into this
situation uh there are a whole lot of
reasons why they could be in this
situation but I I think it's a good bill
I think they worked hard I think they've
got a good bipartisan group of
co-sponsors and now I'm going to support
the bill uh as it as it comes before us
and I hope that of this due on this
committee as well
thank you representative kale thank you
Mr chair
um I don't know whether or not there are
other tools in the Department's toolbox
such as garnishing wages in the event
that someone wasn't paying back and uh
and had a job I don't know if that's a
possibility but I in any event I I think
I I as I said earlier I think the
department handles these situations well
as we have as as already with their with
their current rules and that this uh
bill
unamended is something that I can
support but the amendment not so I I
hope that we will do the not choose not
to fight the
um
the uh perfect for the seek the perfect
and the favor of the kill the good and
just defeat the ICL and let's pass this
thing
thank you so it seems to me that in life
if you look at the incentives you'll
figure out the outcome and it seems to
me that if there is no interest applied
at all then in a world where we have
record high inflation it is actually
profitable not to pay it back so if you
are getting zero you have basically a
zero interest loan and you know whether
you wanted it or not whether it was
intentional or not you have a zero
interest loan and if you invest that in
almost anything else in the meantime
you're actually going to yield a profit
you're gonna make more money by not
paying it back than you would by paying
it back therefore it seems to me that
unless there's some discretion I can't
support I can't support it at all now if
there was discretion where the
department had some ability to say well
you know if you're abusing the system or
you're taking your benefits and you're
putting into Bitcoin or whatever then
you know we're going to charge interest
on that at least that's something to
Tamp down on it but um in lieu of
anything just putting it zero across the
board that just seems like it's a great
way to just be abused
um that's what I was bowling over
earlier and it seems to me pretty any
any smart person who has been overpaid
on employment benefits will figure out
really quick that a zero interest loan
is basically a great way to make some a
quick Buck off an investment
Senator Sullivan
maybe I feel compelled to say that I
don't think anybody is investing their
unemployment benefits unemployment is to
keep people fed and housed
not to be invested in Bitcoin thank you
thank you
we all know how this is going to go down
we all know how the next vote is going
to go down so let's get to it
representative love followed by cell uh
seaworth
yeah earlier we heard thank you Mr chair
we heard about the the videos and stuff
that you know warning against fraud and
uh uh I want to give the people of New
Hampshire a little more credit than
being bona fide idiots if you if you're
sitting there watching this and you see
and you don't know how to uh how to
answer a question there's always
somebody to ask okay
um you know it's it's happened to me
it's probably happened to others
um you know uh
the amendment I thought was great I
won't take a tool out of the out of the
Department's
um toolbox I collect was referred to
um you know we've we can't just be open
for fraud
and uh
you know like I said I'm not going to
vote for for this this bill because of
that thanks
thank you Mr chairman
um
I hear
and and maybe I'm Mister interpreting
but some suggestion that who we're
talking about are people who are
on unemployment eligible for that they
need the money and I just want to
clarify that the category that we're
talking about are people who are not
eligible
they don't need the money at least as
far as we the legislature has defined
that issue of need and they've gotten it
anyway and they won't pay it back and to
me that I all all the issues of someone
who
um
who through no fault of their own got
money that they shouldn't have who are
eligible for the money I I agree with
everything that was said
um but the category that this bill
addresses is just not those people
thank you thank you the emotional floor
is itl has been moved in second Madam
clerk would you call the roll
Vice chair seeworth
and this is on Ito thank you yes
rep Abalone yes rep proud yes rep love
yes rap Boyd yes rep Mason yes
Repco yes rep Drago yes rep Granger yes
ranking damn Sullivan no
rep pretty no rep Cahill no repti
Sylvester no
repo Brian
no
all right Bouchard no
reploid no Brett McKenzie
no
the clerk votes no replica no
and the chair
cheer votes yes
it is 10 to 10.
representative Sullivan you have a
motion
motion on the floor is ought to pass we
have a second
by uh desalvastro
you're
recognized to speak your motion
think I'm ready to vote
we got to give the clerk a second
thank you
for that or the amendment
get this the motion on both
yes
for doing it
all right so
I'm actually
so you saw this film all right uh Madam
with the motion the floor is about to
pass
his call roll
Vice chair seaworth no
rep avaloni rep Prout no prep love no
repoid no rep Mason no rap Cole come no
rep Draco no prep Ranger nope ranking
down Sullivan yes
yes rep key Hill yes repti Silvestro
yeah
rep O'Brien
no
wait excuse me I I get confused I would
like to change my vote to a yay please
thank you
and
sorry I also got confused
um Brett Bouchard yes rep Lloyd yes
Rhett McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes
replica clear
and the chair
turbo snow
10 to 10.
thank you very much
um representative Sullivan will be
getting me your
information
um
well
uh I'd like to have it uh Tuesday so we
could get it to
um our system to be able to do that by
Wednesday so it's
I understand it's a long weekend
all right thank you very much
um we're moving on to Senate Bill 46
relative to electronic payments to
employment
employee debit cards representative uh
Drago
I move itl
s most of the employers itl by
representative Durango seconded by
representative abalani you're recognized
to speak to your uh
to your motion thank you Mr Speaker
I've owned a small business for 17 years
and I guess I'm old school I still pay
by paper check every Friday
um I'm probably the minority now I don't
know
uh our employees as everybody would
probably figure they have basically
three options they can go to the grocery
store get their check cashed they can go
to their personal bank or go to the bank
that we write the check from which
happens to be in town
um with modern technology Mo I would say
90 of our employees just go to their own
bank but with modern technology now they
just take a picture of it and it's
basically
a roundabout way of direct deposit so
it's pretty easy
we don't get many complaints about
the way we pay actually
we don't get complaints and they would
tell us if there was an issue trust me
um
so I think I think this current system
we have works pretty good and uh so this
bill there's quite a few things I can't
support but the one that I really want
to speak to is
um the 24 hour replacement
in the 17 years that I've owned a
business I'd say I've written out
thousands of checks I have never
had an employee lose a paycheck so maybe
I'm lucky I don't think so that just
never happened a few have gone through
the wash
uh I've had a few that have coffee or
some weird substance on them that
they're just going to be cashed we just
wrote a new check everybody was happy
there was no issues
um
as a as a the business I'm in we have to
hand out gas cards and a few credit
cards we try to hand those out to the
people that are responsible
and are trustworthy and even then we
probably lose five to ten cards a year
that we have to replace same size card
as the payroll card that's being
proposed so I have no doubt
that I'm gonna have to replace a lot
more
payroll by using a card rather than a
check just off my experience
and so now as a small business owner as
most of the state is you know we have
lives on the weekend we watch our kids
sports we go away and
and now we have to be called back
to replace a card within 24 hours that
is no fault of our own it's our
employees fault for losing it
and so
so that just puts an extra burden on
business owners across the state
and if you factor in all the hidden fees
that go both to the employers and the
employees as you dive into the system a
little more it seems like it's just
creating it's trying to solve a problem
that I don't think really exists and in
the process of trying to solve that
problem
creates even more burden and more
problems for both the employee and the
employer so with that being said I just
I can't support this bill
I'm sorry
go ahead I apologize I'm sorry my my
mind somewhere else go ahead
representative uh thank you
um I I'd agree with the itl motion it
seems to me as though this uh benefits
uh a small handful of very very large
companies but it doesn't really but it
only serves as a hindrance to most small
companies and it also seems to me as
though this would be enabling
legislation for cbdc's and I am opposed
to cbdc's all over the place so any
legislation that would Aid in the
adoption of Central Bank digital
currencies I would oppose
thank you sorry representative Granger
representative Sullivan
um I agree with the Ico motion
um
I think if a large company likes these
payroll cards
um legislation is already in place that
allows them to use them they can even
encourage their employees to use them by
selling the benefits of them and there
may be benefits of some
um the
and but I still remain skeptical that
all payroll cards are safe and uh user
friendly without fees Etc
um so maintaining the paper check option
I think is critical so um I will vote
Yes on Ito
all right see no other hands
motion of the floor isn't expecting to
legislates moved and seconded Madam
clerk please call the roll
on itl Vice chair seaworth yes
rep avaloni yeah yeah Crouch yes rep
love yes Brett Boyd yes rep Mason yes
rep Holcomb yes Rodrigo YES Prep Granger
yes ranking damn Sullivan yes
yes rep
O'Brien yes right Bouchard yes reploid
yes rep McKenzie yes
the clerk votes yes replica yeah
and Mr chair
yes
unanimous 20-0
the objection to consent
hey none thank you very much
the schedule Brian 140 12 45 says since
we are still behind sorry Mom
I'm opening here executive session on
Senate Bill 193 recognized
representative seaworth thank you Mr
chairman uh once again I'd like to move
on to pass with an amendment uh
2023-1800.
second
yes motion on the floor
um
octopus the amendment amendment number
two zero two three dash one eight zero
zero H last one seconded by
representative I wouldn't have a copy of
the amendment
first
correct well we're discussing the
amendment first yeah
representative uh see worth you're
recognize to uh speak your motion
thank you very much Mr chairman
um in this case this stems from a
conversation that some of us who are
hanging around after the public Hearing
in the room and uh the discussion came
up with it 10 days what is what does
that mean and I said well it
I I heard it meant two weeks and
somebody else said no no I think it
means 10 calendar days and we we
couldn't really agree on what it meant
and it seems to me that we would all
benefit from being specific and saying
what we mean so this amendment the
difference between what's before you and
the amendment and what was in the
original bill is one word and
um it's in that uh first line of the
bolded text what's added by the original
bill it says now within 10 business days
instead of just within 10 days so I
would ask that you support this uh
clarification to the original language
just as as I was trying to figure out
and and
it was back and forth people weren't
sure exactly what they meant I did some
searching I couldn't find the main law
easily but as I was searching I found
other states and what was common was
either 14 or 15 days so I think I think
the 10 business days matches the
original intent I think it makes it
consistent with other states that have
similar laws so I would ask for your
support thank you
because I was Sullivan followed by
Cahill
um I think I would have interpreted it
as 10 consecutive days but I would agree
with uh representative seaworth that 10
business days is better gives a little
more time and it is uh not going to be
confusing to anyone uh so I thank him
for the uh Amendment and I will support
it
representative Cahill followed by
baroody thank you Mr chair and and I I
will support the amendment I do have a
concern as to whether those 10 days are
using the 24-hour clock which I know has
been a point of discussion before
report
I do appreciate your levity
representative
and the other hands
representative McKenzie clarification so
in the case of a holiday that falls
within that 10 business days absolutely
then we refer back to the Cahill
Amendment
um I don't believe a um holiday is
called considered a business day I think
that's pretty consistent uh anyone
if I may respond I thought about this uh
one of my first ideas was to be really
specific about what we meant by
yesterdays and no days and I finally
decided simpler is better there may be a
case where two sides of a negotiating
table can't agree whether this day
counts and that would end up before the
pelrb as would any other issue where the
two sides absolutely cannot agree
um in the end I decided that using
business days
exempts weekends exempts federal
holidays I think it's commonly
understood and it should be adequate for
of of the issues that come up in the
negotiation representative Rudy
thank you Mr chairman I I
agree with the amendment too if somebody
gave notice like uh tomorrow and then
you had a three-day weekend you got
seven days gone almost eight days gone
already uh maybe four days gone to give
a very short period of time to react and
uh I think that the business days really
would work a lot better
seeing no other hands
we have a motion on amendment number
2023-18008 it's been moved in seconded
um Madam clerk please call the roll
Vice chair seeworth yes yes
rep proud YES Prep love yes Brett Boyd
yes Brett Mason yes Repco come yes rep
Drago yes rep Granger yes ranking damn
Sullivan yes reprodi
yes
rep Cahill yes rep D Sylvester yeah rep
O'Brien yes Brett Bouchard yes rep Lloyd
yes Rhett McKenzie yes the clerk votes
yes replica yes
yes and Mr chair yes
20-0 motion passes the bills open for
further
business representative see worth
I move out to pass as amended
I'll second it in my left second thing
you most certainly are
seconded by the clerk
representative seaworth here recognized
to speak and I'll
I've said enough I'll leave it to
someone else thank you
representative
thank you Mr chairman
um
we heard a couple bills earlier that
we're trying to move things that should
be negotiated into a contract into law
and we properly dispose of those
um I I feel that this also should be
part of the collective bargaining
process is to set the days four times to
meet
um and not have this in law because this
is taking something that should be part
of the collective bargaining process and
putting it into law which could be used
on either side to play the gotcha game
with the opposing side thank you Mr
chairman
you're welcome
represent O'Brien uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for allowing me
to sit into this afternoon and sorry
about the confusion earlier but sitting
on the other side of the table I'm sure
representative uh McKenzie could agree
we both did it if you got tied up on
arguing about days and stuff like that
you get deeper problems in negotiations
than really that and to make it uh part
of the collective bargaining agreement
if you can agree on a day you're not
going to get anything into the agreement
so therefore I think it's kind of moot
in my personal opinion and therefore you
know I support the bill
thank you representative Sullivan
thank you
um
first of all this um
probably wouldn't come up here very
often I would agree with representative
O'Brien that uh
um it would come up in situations that
are truly dysfunctional
um but then it would be needed
um and um
in answer to another thought that was
expressed earlier the uh the dates and
deadlines for giving notice are actually
in statute so this is an issue that is
addressed in statute already and
actually the deadlines for completing
negotiations
um I don't think are in statute but I
think they've been established by
through the Supreme Court
um either that or they're in statute but
bottom line is much of the schedule for
the bargaining process
is uh is determined by legislation so I
think it's appropriate here and again it
would not come up very often but when it
would come up it would be
um perhaps desperately needed because
clearly the parties are not cooperating
at all with each other thank you
another one
I didn't know if there was another hand
down there
so I am caught between a rock and a hard
place representative Sullivan
because number one I do agree with the
representative avaloni
that we have dispensed with bills here
because it was the agreement of both
sides of the aisle here that we
shouldn't tell
we shouldn't put things in legislation
should be dealt with at the bargaining
table between the parties usually done
by a representative of the management
team and a representative of the of the
uh the bargaining group uh they get
together and they kind of like a jury
you know they said a time schedule and
what have you
on the other hand
I'm
very cognizant
of the time period of which we are in
right now in the time period we're in
right now is the house doesn't like what
the Senate is doing the Senate doesn't
like what the house is doing on certain
things and we're going to mess with each
other's legislation until we get what we
want
and I would hate this to go to committee
a conference
and not have any uh members of
Republican members of the committee be
on
the committee of conference
to work something out
my entire caucus is against
uh this bill
so I am going to vote in favor of the
bill with the vice chairman
because I
would rather be involved
than not involved
should this go to the committee
conference since we've amended the bill
well it's a simple thing they should
probably concur
but you never know
um
so
parliamentary procedure over over
politics I guess
so
um anyone else uh did I did I give
everyone what was the word represent
McKenzie did I give you an inspirational
representative proud they give you
inspiration
okay so seeing none for all the call the
role it's ought to uh to Pastor the
amendment Adam Clark
foreign
yes Brett babyloni
proud no prep love no Brett Boyd no
Brett Mason no Jeff Holcomb no type
Drago no prep Granger nope
ranking damn Sullivan yes
reprodi yes
rep Cahill yes rep D Silvestro yes rep
O'Brien yes Brett Bouchard yes rep Lloyd
yes
Mackenzie yes clerk votes yes rep
LeClaire yes
Mr chair
yes
12 to eight
the motion passes
we're moving up we have a minority
there'll be a Minority Report I'm sure
there will be Minority Report
representative
uh Tuesday of next week
all right Senate Bill 269 I would like
everyone's attention first because I
need to explain something
and I can do this quietly and you cannot
understand why or I can lay all the
cards in the table and I'm going to
choose to do the latter
Senate Bill 269 comes with us
bipartisan
from the Senate
rarely do I agree with my senator
and um
I agree with her on this
um
I do not want to amend the bill
I think the amendment is significant
enough
requiring documentation
requiring
written notice
people to keep written notice in
gratuity perpetuity I guess for certain
things requires a new hearing
and we do not have time for a hearing
at my disposal I have the ability
to reject the amendment
I have been
always very
um
as Fair as I can
with representative uh Cahill
letting him bring motions even though
there weren't enough votes to pass his
motion uh to allow and to put his motion
out front
and I I try to be as is uh so we could
get it on the record and I try to be as
um Fair as I can
but this is the way this scenario would
go down
if I
make the motion not to accept
you can challenge me
if you challenge me it'll probably be a
10 to 10 vote
which means the challenge would go
nowhere
we can then vote
on the bill as is
that vote would be possibly a 10 10.
would then go to the floor as it is
let's say on the floor you do
get an amendment
passed goes to committee a conference
okay the committee a conference
pretty confident is going to be thrown
out by the Senate because the Senate
wants this the way they want it
um or we could also have a motion to
retain this bill
which I'm not sure is a good thing but
maybe the Department of Labor will lay
off for a year and until we get it so
um
I woke up at 6 15 this morning which I
usually
am sleeping soundly
thinking about this and I don't like
doing that
I like waking up at 6 15 in the morning
and thinking about legislation
um
but I wanted to know
what I'm going to do and why because
what I think could happen
you could agree with me you can disagree
with me
but I plan to not accept the motion if
there is a 10 10 to
uh not to not pass the bill or excuse me
if the emotion of ought to pass does not
pass then the motion itl uh passes
that's a positive motion or they're both
excuse me if they both in the past 10 to
10 it goes to the floor with no
recommendation
um
you can fight there
and if it passes it's going to committee
a conference
so that is the position I'm going to
make I think it's too significant
a
um an amendment
um
to not have a hearing and I can tell you
um if it does for some reason
um if I'm incorrect or some of the votes
today in the next half an hour and if it
does pass with this amendment I think
there's going to be a
some voices like you haven't heard in a
long time
from a certain industry and from your
senators
so
what I want
versus what I think is going to happen
versus what I think is good legislating
I'm trying to put them all together
so that is what I'm going to do and that
is why and I thought everyone should
know why
representative Sullivan
thank you for your explanation
um
um I I don't know that I agree with you
that this requires a hearing but I
respect that that's your your thinking
um
if that is where we're at what I would
suggest so that we can have
a full consideration of all aspects of
this uh this bill and the potential
amendment I would suggest retaining the
bill
um would allow us to uh to have that
hearing I don't I I agree that a hearing
now would be
um
impossible no no time
um but
um retaining the bill would allow us to
have a hearing
have an opportunity to um to vote on
that Amendment or whichever way it goes
and then vote uh on on the bill itself
either amended it or not
um so that would be my request and my
suggestion thank you representative
Cahill
Mr chair and thank you for your
explanation of the uh the Parliamentary
situation the political situation
uh I don't want to make a lot of trouble
here it's never my intention as I
believe I've communicated to the
industry that I'm trying to be helpful I
support well I'm not crazy about tip
sharing if and I I think it's crazy that
they can't bring the topic up and talk
about it as it's part of their work
environment how the employees are to be
paid I support that concept I'm just I
merely offered a way for them to do a
better job of it and if you'll indulge
me for just a moment I'd like to I'd
like to read something here which I
think is an illustration of why this is
needed
um
it was a very busy night the manager had
an extra busser come in to assist we tip
out buses five percent of the total
amount of tip to DeWalt servers because
we shared the tips in the pool the
manager told us we should tip out more
than five percent because there was
three buses and not the usual two
when the manager went into the office
one of the more experienced servers said
is our tips she can tell us how to split
them
so this is an example if you didn't have
that more experienced person who knew
what their rights and responsibilities
were well then they they probably would
have just well if that's what you wanted
us to do I guess we'll just give more of
our tips
you see this is a problem and I the
document that uh uh was as I understood
the industry like the document that I've
offered as a as a template as guidance
and they would be happy to send it to
their members but not every restaurant
entity with tip workers is a member of
the New Hampshire Restaurant Association
this is why I brought this amendment
which I think would be protective of
both sides of the equation
so if you don't want to uh if you feel
that this is futile and not worth the
efforts to protect the worker and the
business then I won't offer the
amendment and we'll go home early
but it's it's with regret
I recognize
I am pausing because I am thinking
oh I appreciate that you know
um
I'm gonna call a five minute recess I
want to speak with my vice chairman if
that's all right with everybody sure
that's right
it dawned on me I didn't explain to some
of the newbies something some of you
will remember this about five years ago
I used to run those tough mudder things
you ever seen those things I've run
three of those stupid things
and the last thing you do is you get
shocked when you go through oh like an
idiot why am I doing this a third time
I contracted uh
Lyme disease
on one of my runs
and I didn't know what was going on and
I was messed up for three or four months
and and finally I went to the doctor and
they said
you're a mess pal so as a result
sometimes I forget certain things I'll
look at Dave duvet and I'll say his name
ten times and tomorrow I'll look at them
and I can't remember his name
and it takes me a couple seconds
so today I was looking at representative
Granger
and at back at the time my my vice
chairman at the time
um
um would fill in the blanks for me
sometimes
because I forget names and I haven't
done it in a while so I apologize
representative Granger but uh I still
have those lingering
lingering things so
um thank you everyone for um
were agreeing to listen to me and and
going forward uh we're gonna uh now open
the hearing
on Senate Bill 269 and I uh call in
representative abalani for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass
motion the floor is ought to pass is
that second of my representative
Sullivan
savalani you're recognized to speak and
then representative Sullivan thank you
Mr chairman
um
when this bill first came before us
um I I had some issues with it
um upon talking with the people that
have put it together
um
have put my mind at ease upon certain
things and this seems to be an issue
that the few restaurants are having
with the Department of Labor at this
time and this would clarify going
forward
the issues and problems that they're
having right now and I would
move that everyone support it as it's
written
you know Sullivan like he said
I
was made aware of a problem with the
Tipping law
seven or eight years ago
now Senator Murphy and I sat down at
this bar
with another representative and had a
couple beers and figured this out
because a local large local
establishment had been fined by the
Department of Labor for having one of
those buckets or spittoons behind the
bar
um and they would put all their tips in
there
and then they would spread them out
amongst the bartenders and some of the
hostesses or waitresses at the end of
the night
and that was against the law that was
not allowed in the state of New
Hampshire and we found in reviewing the
Tipping law there were still laws about
pin boys anyone know what a pin boy is
the guys that used to put up the bowling
pins
before there was electronic bowling pins
and and there was laws and we saw in the
books about how much you could tip
someone to Pursuit you in a certain
place in a movie theater
so going back number of years so we met
at these things and everyone seemed to
like it for a while uh I think it's been
seven or eight years and they like the
the uh the plan
uh now we have a little tweak to it I
fully believe as I think everyone if I
can impart only one thing on this
committee ever
number one
is the tips are the money of the
employees
no ifs ands or buts about it
we should always be careful to protect
the employees and those tips
from owners
it's not theirs
never has been never should be
someone brought to me a a company that
wanted to come in here and open a bunch
of restaurants they called me up and
said we'd like to have lunch with you
and see if we can uh the management
wants to control what happens with the
tips I said sorry we're not even going
to have lunch
that's not going to happen in the New
Hampshire legislature
so I appreciate the clarification and
I'm not against future clarification but
I'd like that clarification to be worked
out with
um with the the
association parties that are involved
so I will support this but please
recommend that I think I would like all
of my Republican members to to I think
they all agree with me and I know my
Democrat members do that
the tips are the employees period
that being said
Madam clerk please call the well
um the motion is uh to pass Vice chair
seeworth yes
rep avaloni
rep Prout yes rep love YES Prep Boy Yes
rep Mason yes Repco come yes rap Drago
YES Prep Granger YES Prep a ranking damn
Sullivan yes
okay
rapper Rudy yes rep Cahill
yes that was gracious
uh rep D Silvestro yeah
repo Brian yes Brett Bouchard yes
reploid yes Brett McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes replicaair yes and Mr chair
yes 20-0 the motion passes
yes
without objection thank you
is there any further business to come in
front of this committee
there is
um a few things we have to do
um representative Sullivan and I have
already been talking about and I'm going
to start them pretty soon like the next
couple weeks we're going to try to set a
schedule up to start talking about the
retained bills I don't want these to sit
around until October and then we kind of
rush through them we have two or three
very complex bills
um representative Sullivan I have come
to a agreement to disagree on one aspect
of one which we will try to work through
uh and the other ones so I am going to
ask I will be contacting some of you for
volunteers I'd like a few more people on
some of these committees I understand we
only had a couple people on these
subcommittees before but I'm going to
want a few more people involved if they
can I don't want anyone to be on more
than one if they don't have to I respect
um the time frame representative
Sullivan how long do you think we have
we have uh
um June
I think it
you and I had this conversation and um
you speculated that the speaker might
allow meetings during July and August
that wasn't allowed last year and that
kind of cramped our style
um so um
frankly if we could squeeze it all into
June
um
that would be if we could get as much as
possible done in June and then maybe
having a meeting or two later
um I I also want to have some respect
for people's summertime
um you know we've all been at it January
through June
um it might be nice to have some time
off in July and August so if we sprinkle
meetings throughout July and August we
we can spoil people's opportunity to get
out travel and do something with family
or
Alone
um we have four
four we have three
we have one sure we have turkot yeah I
don't think that's going well right OSHA
yep and marijuana medical marijuana yep
I thought there was one more there's
three years there's one more
um there's one more there is
anybody anybody remember
discharge volunteer oh that's that's it
that's the one that's it because I want
to that's right
right so there's four
um but I think we need to work need
working at least two yeah I agree
um the um
I I don't want to yank people up here
we're going to see do uh okay first of
all Brian and I in the in the chairs
meeting chair and vice chair meeting
there was indication that they were
going to allow because we had so many
retained bills especially like Commerce
Commerce didn't want to have any ten
tens so they have 25 retained bills and
so they're going to need the summer to
do that okay so I do believe the speaker
will allow that was that the same
indication you you got from that meet
from some of those discussions my
meeting
way earlier than yours and the way I
understood it is what the speaker was
allowing was work before the summer
which in some years they do not allow
you to even start on retained bills
until after the Summer's over and this
year he will allow once the meeting
rooms are freed up with Senate bills we
can start in June
um but I did not hear that he I think I
thought that he was still discouraging
the July and August what I would like to
do representative Sullivan is to have at
least one hearing for each of them in
June let's get to the point where we
know what we agree on
okay and there's a couple things that we
don't agree on that we can at least see
if we can work on
during the summer uh you know we don't
have to yeah I think if we have one
meeting in early in in June as we can
manage then we can figure out exactly
where we stand with uh the speakers uh
allowances and uh and then we can use
that meeting to schedule future meetings
in July August June July August or
September I will email you with a date
I'd like to do within the next couple
weeks in June see if you can make it
with folks
the the only it would be good I think if
we knew a day of the week
so for in terms of planning if we knew
it was going to be Thursday afternoons
of what I'm going to try to do
representative McKenzie is I want to
find out exactly uh from the speaker's
office
what they think the next three Thursdays
are going to be like because Anthony you
know they say oh hold it open for
everybody well you know we got to see
how many bills that all of us and
they're ready to do I mean does anyone
know has anyone heard through
scuttlebutt how many bills we have left
I thought the next three were all
deadline dates at various types of
deadlines
right but I mean are we gonna have full
days ready for some of these things
right now we got to sit around and wait
for the budget
okay and and then everyone's kind of
putting all kinds of amendments on each
other's bills on either side you know
and then the marijuana thing showed up
yesterday and or whatever so all these
different things but if if we're not
going to have if we're gonna have a
house session next Thursday and the
Thursday after they don't have enough
because they're waiting
um then I'm going to schedule it on
something like that no I don't think
we'll have him on Thursday
I don't think we'll have one this
Thursday no because it's Memorial Day we
could sort of a tradition okay
we have had communities meet during that
we've been told that the next uh meeting
is the eighth yeah
so okay but I'll I'll find out
afterwards if they're going to have one
the next week after that
what they're thinking of this is
the three that he announced and I think
uh representative proud is correct that
these are all deadlines so there will be
sessions it is a question of which ones
might be long and which might be short
but right
so I'm gonna try to find out because if
if the eighth
if the eighth is um we meet at 10
o'clock in the morning in the first two
hours we do most concurrences and
there's two or three bills and that's it
we're going to be done in the coldest
until one o'clock or something I'm gonna
kind of want to yes I agree it's like
we're here exactly
all right thank you anything else in
front of the committee
representative avaloni I volunteer for
the
the marijuana bill
okay
all right
thank you everyone
free samples uh
thank you uh
representative Lloyd and O'Brien
oh
yeah and uh seeing no further business
to the uh executive session and the
meeting of the labor committee is
adjourned